in the mood for swords sorcerers and
stories containing fantastical elements
that could never exist in the real world
we've scoured the pages of rotten
tomatoes to find the most critically
beloved examples of the fantasy genre
to be fair lots of disney films could
have made this list but it's hard to
argue with the critics here
1991's beauty and the beast a staple of
disney's early 90's pre-pixar
renaissance is as good as animation
and cinema gets based on both the 1740
short story and the equally great fringe
film from 1946
this animated classic won overwhelming
critical acclaim upon release
and for good reason it's the story of
belle a young french girl who's captured
by
and falls in love with a reclusive beast
who only has
until the last petal falls from a
magical rose to fall in love himself
and revert back to human form otherwise
he'll stay a beast forever
meanwhile the egomaniacal gaston
convinces belle's neighbors that she's
in terrible danger
and leads them on a quest to kill the
beast so he can have bell to himself
also there's a living candlestick whose
best friend is a clock
and a teapot with a cup for a son and a
walking chest of drawers and
you know what let's just watch it again
it has to be something very special
written and directed by guillermo del
toro of the shape of water and pacific
rim fame
pan's labyrinth is truly a masterful
cinematic fable
in a style not unlike alice in
wonderland but considerably darker and
more mature
pan tells the story of ophelia a young
spanish girl living during the spanish
civil war
after traveling to meet her new
rebel-hunting stepfather
she stumbles upon a stone labyrinth
filled with mystical creatures
the fawn guarding the entrance to this
maze believes ophelia to be the
reincarnation of princess moana
who's prophesied to one day return to
unite the underworld
thon tasks ophelia with various quests
such as retrieving a key from the belly
of a great toad
retrieving a dagger from the child
eating pale man and spilling the blood
of an
innocent to open a portal the fawn
claims that success will restore her to
the throne
however things go south in the world
above as her stepfather continues his
ruthless campaign
and ophelia's ability to navigate the
struggles of both places is put to the
test
we won't spoil the surprises but we will
emphasize just how otherworldly and
magical this film feels
as evidenced by its rotten tomato score
the critics agreed and put it on
countless 2006
best of the year lists if you haven't
seen it do so now
we promise you won't be disappointed all
three lord of the rings films were
fantastic but you really can't beat the
two towers
the action follows a rather bittersweet
ending to 2001's the fellowship of the
ring
in which boromir died frodo struck out
alone
sam nearly drowned getting to him and
mary and pippen were captured by orcs
aragorn legolas and gimli head out not
to escort frodo to mordor
but instead to save the other two
hobbits their journey leads them to a
resurrected gandalf
and into rohan which is besieged by the
forces of the evil wizard
saruman who's working for the big bad
sauron
meanwhile bumbling hobbits mary and
pippen managed to convince a group of
walking talking trees to take the fight
to saramon after he slaughtered their
brethren in a deforestation bench
further east frodo and sam capture the
ring obsessed gollum
and force him to guide them to mordor
only to get caught themselves by foot
soldiers from gondor
as film highlights go audiences are
still amazed by the battle of helms deep
it doesn't quite surpass saving private
ryan's opening omaha beach sequence on
the list of all-time greatest battle
scenes but it came damn close
and hasn't been top sense all forms of
animation have their merits but there's
just something about stop motion that's
simply spellbinding
maybe it's the slightly off-time
movement that gives it an otherworldly
feel
or the knowledge that an enormous amount
of effort went into crafting every
moment
whatever the case may be it doesn't get
better than the nightmare before
christmas it tells the story of pumpkin
king jack skellington
who tires of the same spooky routine
year after year and tries to sell the
idea of christmas to a town that can't
imagine a holiday
other than the one after which they've
been named how about it
think you can manage a one and a two and
a three
and
the songs are great and the characters
are unforgettable but it's the wild
dreamlike union of christmas and
halloween aesthetics that really draws
you in and blows you away
you might call it the halloween miss
spirit you can't explain how or why it
works
you just know that like peanut butter
and jelly it does
food metaphors aside we should all
probably re-watch the nightmare before
christmas
it's a halloween must tradition it's
been pointed out that
like the books upon which they're based
the harry potter movies grew up with
their fans
the sorcerer's stone is pretty much a
kitty flick but by the time we get to
the second half of the deathly hallows
things have changed simply put this is a
war movie
albus dumbledore has been dead for a
while now snape
has seemingly joined the death eaters
and voldemort
now aware of harry ron and hermione's
quest to get rid of his horcruxes
plans to kill potter and crush hogwarts
into dust
it's violent dark truly scary in parts
seemingly hopeless in others and yet
despite all the blood and rubble
it never loses touch with the simple
message that made the franchise so
magical in the first place
that with courage and the help of
friends good can always triumph over
evil
maybe that's not always true in the real
world but the deathly hallows part 2
invites us to a place where even a small
bit of hope makes loss and suffering
worth enduring
stop animation films are hard enough to
make that the market has never been
saturated with them
and each installment still feels special
wes anderson and tim burton have given
us a few great ones
and coraline very nearly made this list
but according to the critics the one to
beat in the 21st century so far is
2016's
kubo and the two strings it's the story
of kubo
an eye-patched kid on the hunt for his
missing father who fights the evil
forces of the moon king
if that all sounds rather
straightforward and generic it's
anything but
there's music that makes origami come to
life animal charms that become magical
talking monkeys
a beetle samurai enchanted weapons in
forbidden places
and towering monsters guarding them in
the end we learn a powerful lesson about
family
redemption and how we're defined by our
memories it's a gorgeous feat of
filmmaking that refuses to hold your
hand
or bore you with shallow cliches and if
you haven't seen it you're in for a
thrilling
emotional treat nobody in the history of
film
other than perhaps walt disney has done
more to legitimize animation than
legendary studio ghibli co-founder hayo
miyazaki
the mere mention of his name draws nods
of reverence from fans
there's a good reason for this too his
anime films such as 1986's castle in the
sky
1988's my neighbor totoro and 1997's
princess mononoke
are consistently boundary pushing
breathtaking and
all-around wonderful but 2001's spirited
away
about a young girl who encounters a
world filled with bizarre spirits
has transcended even these achievements
and is frequently referenced not only as
one of the best animated features
but as one of the greatest films ever
made it's also one of the most
successful animated movies
raking in 347 million dollars on a 15 to
20 million dollar budget
and beating out titanic to become the
highest grossing film
ever released in japan it won the
academy award for best animated feature
at the 75th oscars
and its influence hasn't diminished in
the years since its release
in 2016 the bbc asked 177 film critics
what the best movies of the 21st century
have been
and spirited away beat out every
animated feature to come in an
impressive fourth place overall
the next year the new york times gave it
a second place finish over the same time
period
who said fantasy has to take itself
seriously director rob reiner
known for 1989's when harry met sally
1992's a few good men
in 1984's this is spinal tap adapted the
princess bride in 1987.
based on william goldman's 1973 novel of
the same name
bride is a laugh riot that both pokes
fun at and celebrates fantasy tropes in
equal measure
it's the story of a lowly farmhand
wesley who befriends a vengeful
swordmaster and a giant
the band sets off to rescue wesley's
love princess buttercup from the evil
prince humperdinck
and his chief lieutenant count rugen do
we have to explain it
come on we know you've seen the princess
bride at the very least you've
undoubtedly heard enough quotes from it
that you might as well have seen it
it's up there with monty python and the
holy grail and borat is one of the most
quoted comedies of all time
if you were trying to determine the most
influential film of all time
it'd be tough to beat the wizard of oz
the ruby red slippers
there's no place like home cowardly lion
toto
and of course
seriously so many elements of this movie
have become timeless staples of american
pop culture that there's hardly another
film that can compete
yeah it lost out to gone with the wind
at the academy awards but who needs an
oscar when you're the most viewed motion
picture in history
as determined by the library of congress
the point is the wizard of oz is kind of
a big deal and critical acclaim for the
film
both at the time and in the years since
has been truly universal
we tell you to go see it but if you
haven't yet you probably don't know what
the internet is and will never come
across this video
according to rotten tomatoes 2010's how
to train your dragon is the most
critically acclaimed animated fantasy
film
ever made and why shouldn't it be it's
relatively recent vintage doesn't it all
detract from its stunning visuals the
fantastic performances of the voice
actors
john powell's unforgettable musical
score or the entrancing story of a
scrawny underdog kid
trying to prove himself to his
tough-as-nails viking clan
all while befriending healing and
training a dragon enemy
it's also a highly successful film one
that launched arguably the most beloved
dreamworks animated franchise other than
shrek
these days it can seem like the mark of
a successful movie is getting at least
one sequel
and dragons has two 2014's how to train
your dragon 2
in 2019's how to train your dragon the
hidden world
with rotten tomato scores of 92 and 91
respectively both of these smashes only
just missed making this list
we would have loved to have them but the
2010 original flies highest of all
mary poppins joins fewer than 1 000
films with 100 on rotten tomatoes
not even the most hard to please critic
could snub this all-time disney classic
perhaps because it's been a staple of
virtually every western childhood since
its 1964 release
it's worth noting that of all the
masterpieces walt disney released during
his lifetime
mary poppins is the only one to have
received the best picture nomination at
the academy awards
also worth noting that was only one of
13 nominations it received that year
it won five best actress for julie
andrews
best film editing best visual effects
best original musical score
and best original song for chim chim
cherry the film's shortcomings aren't
just few and far between but are now
considered strengths
dick van dyke's atrocious cockney accent
for example is hilarious and endearing
i know that so you're wet anywhere
mary poppins on top of that mary poppins
visual effects put the viewer in a
visual time machine back to the golden
era of film where you had to take what
you had and make it work the result
is a disney knockout check out one of
our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you